so
hi i'm john david dalton and today i'm
going to be talking about fearless
browser test automation
all right
so a little bit of background
i am a contributor to lodash
lodash is a
before i begin how many people use
lodash
all right
how many people use underscore
all right get out get out just right now
no that's okay you can stay
i also help and contribute to underscore
two
but today i'm going to be talking about
browser test automation and what i did
with lowdash to
to tackle that
when i created lodash one of the things
i wanted to do to
to separate myself from the competition
was to list the browsers i test
and that meant testing those browsers
and so when i first released lowdash i
was very
accommodating to testing lots of
browsers i said i support chrome 5 and i
support firefox uh what is it now 29 or
something like all the ranges all the
browsers and that meant testing all of
those things um and so that took about
two days to do
and we had 38 or 34 releases in that
year which meant a lot of time spent
testing and i knew there had to be a
better way
but before i start
jsconf is a conference of firsts i
started lowdash after jsconf one year um
and i was inspired by jen's talk on on
george sort so i'd like to announce that
we will be getting short buy it's a it's
a drop in replacement for jort sort but
it is faster and more consistent
yeah
thank you
all right
you can follow along on some of the uh
the q and a's of of uh the uh my testing
story at uh sauce labs they did a blog
post uh where i answer uh a lot of the
questions i'll be talking about today uh
so there's the short url there bitly
sauce
hyphen lodash
with no hyphen on the lowdash
all right manual testing made me do this
it was horrible
it's lots of browsers it's variations
it's versions it's virtual machines and
it's time so i mentioned that i test a
lot of browsers
and i'm sure everyone's setup looks like
this
so we all have our chrome browsers right
we all have our ies
we all have our firefoxes our operas and
our safaris and i tested on all of those
manually opening up the browser going to
the unit test running the unit test
doing a drop down menu to change out the
file in the build and doing that over
and over and over and over again and
that just sucked up my weekends
so
so i wanted to automate this but the
problem was uh it was intimidating there
wasn't a lot of documentation around
browser test automation
i noticed that it seemed to be
mysterious and very hard
in fact i could not do it i had to ask
the the twitter sphere
for help and someone actually jumped in
and fixed bugs and dependencies of mpm
packages
and to get it to work for me and then
once they did that then i was able to
kind of refine it and clean it up and i
took it on from there
and so i'm going to be covering some of
the roadblocks that i ran into
getting testing started
so let me go back
all right
if you noticed i had a lot of virtual
machines too that eats up my hard drive
this box is basically just good for
javascript there's almost no hard drive
space left it's all just vms
all right so lowdash tests on
five browsers that's uh five
environments so it's not just
it's not just node or or the browsers
it's ringo rhino norwal i'm about to do
nashorn which is like the new rhino
and i even test on things like adobe
illustrator
but that's not included in my automation
i just manually do that one
there's also build so it's not just the
monolithic build because we've had a lot
of talks on modules right
so lodash supports custom builds we're
one of the most customized libraries out
there so there's the amd build there's
the common js build which is different
than the mpm build
and all of these are tested and they all
run in the same unit test so i have one
unit test file
and every single one of these builds can
run against that unit test so i know
that each one's covered
and
testing it in the browser it's the same
thing it's not just the monolithic build
it's the amd build it's the underscore
build it's the backbone build it's
it's the com the compat build it's the
modern build it's the non-minified
version it's the minified version of
each one of these things because bugs
creep in to lots of different areas
closure compiler advanced mode uh likes
to think it knows more than you do
and we'll say hey this code can never be
reached but engines are buggy and lots
of places where code can should never be
reached can get reached if you're doing
a feature test
and so closure compiler will like to
strip out those feature tests
so i have to put them back in and i have
unit tests to make sure that the
minified versions work correctly
this says 30 versions i have since
pulled back because even automating it
that's still a crazy amount of browsers
so i follow the jquery
method of this which is take the current
browser and go one back
so i test that except for things like ie
where i still support ie6
and safari where i support uh safari
five and that's mainly because things
like uh phantom js still use
ish
five-ish for for its web kits so i make
sure that i support that too
okay so i said there's got to be a
better way and there is and it's browser
test automation
there's a couple of options out there
there's there's sauce labs which i'll be
talking about today and there's tesling
which is a different way to do it
just because i'm talking about sauce
labs doesn't mean it's the one true way
it's the way that i i went um if you if
you use uh tesling or you use browser
stack or you use something else as long
as you're doing test automation you're
in a better place
so i would encourage anyone to just to
to read up on these different options
and pick the one that's right for you i
like sauce labs
let's see if i get into that real quick
i might because it has a view of
you can do lots of things with your unit
tests so for example here's an example
here's here's my my my page layout here
for the sauce labs
you can go along or
play along with me here
and follow along that is and go to sauce
lab slash u dash to see the recently run
unit test i ran these tests about 30
minutes ago so it was a really big
chance because they could there could
have been mass fails there could have
been instability in the the test
automation uh but in a little bit i'll
explain why that wasn't the case and why
they're all green
you'll notice that it has the name of
the test it has the os it has tags with
it too so you can associate with your
unit test run keywords so for example
when i'm testing the compat build and
the minified build it's compat
production and it's also the underscore
unit test suite so it says underscore
and so using that on the search session
name i can i can narrow down
tests by the tags and the tests i can
also
you'll see here it has the commit hash
there too so i can look up test by
commit hash and then of course it has
the the name of the test so it has
things like the underscore test the
backbone tests and the low dash tests
because lodash tests against underscores
unit tests it also tests against
backbone too to make sure that there's
that compatibility there
all right
so to get started i used travis ci
uh q unit uh
sauce labs supports jasmine mocha
and a few others it also supports a
custom
unit testing libraries and i'll kind of
i'll go into that in a little bit later
too i use i don't use grunt but it is
optional
how many people are using grunt
all right so if you're using grunt
there's a really easy way to get browser
test automation set up
and i'll talk about that too and then
you'll need a sauce labs account and
that's just real easy you sign up you
get your account you get a
api key and that's what you'll need
okay so i make travis ci do all the
things i don't do i don't use grunt in
my case because grunt traditionally has
has used lodash too and i kind of wanted
to have this pure dependency
stack where i wasn't using anything else
that was using me to test myself
so i make grunt or travis do it and that
looks something like this
this massive yml file uh go
to
uh my github repo for lodash and it's
load dot travis yml
to see this this pretty hefty yml file
and what it's doing is it's
running each one of these various
versions of the build so it's running
phantom js norwall um
rhino
uh it's running the various builds as
well too and then somewhere in there
towards the bottom you'll see the sauce
labs
runs too
so i throw my command in there
to
call a helper file which establishes the
tunnel
sets up the tests runs the tests and
we'll actually retry the test too
all right so this is what it looks like
on travis ci when it's actually running
the jobs you'll see it says the name of
the browser the version and passed and
if there was an issue there it would say
failed and how many if there was a
connection issue it would say
what the connection issue was it may
even give you a link for more
information about that issue uh too but
when when everything is good you'll see
things like this where it just says past
and you'll see there too that i have the
fancy colors and that's because chalk
which i mentioned earlier
here oops it's not there
it's over here somewhere i use chalk to
color that again optional
all right
what i do now is i i take it up a notch
and i do code coverage too so not only
is it test automation it's code coverage
as well and i use istanbul to
do a pass over
low dash and then i feed that to
coveralls and what's nice about
coveralls
coveralls is kind of a bit beta-ish
but for me at least with the modular
build so the modularized build is the
screenshot that i'm showing here it can
show
module per module or in this case like
method per method and show me how much i
have coverage for that method and i just
used that today to find dead code in two
of my methods which was uh a sign and
merge i had a little if statement that
was never being hit and it wasn't a
coverage gap it was a usability gap like
there's no way to actually get to that
chunk of code so i was able to spot dead
code and remove it from my build and
then of course that increases the the
coverage
percent as well so this says uh 90 in
this file or that file overall it's
tilde 100 so if you go to the the actual
interface it says 100 so i'm rocking
about 100 test coverage there
um
so to to do this the npm depths this is
the one where where chalk was there um i
use chalk i use a static file server uh
this case was ecstatic um i tried a few
others and i'm not a pro at like all
things server related
so i found one that worked
request and then sauce tunnel now um
just uh just a few weeks ago i would
have had to put like an asterisk next to
sauce tunnel
about connection problems and using a
very specific patch which was a
roadblock that i had to overcome but
they have since fixed that so now you
just use sauce tunnel and everything
works it's using sauce connect version 4
which is an updated version
it should be faster more reliable
all the things
so some of the cool things you can do
with browser test automation
and one of the reasons i use sauce labs
is because it gives you more control
i did not want to do
i did not want as much control as like
web driver so that's like scripting all
kinds of things and i did not want that
but i wanted a little bit more control
because one of the things i test is ie
compat modes so you all know that
there's there's compat modes in ie and
that they're not exact emulations of
their mode so if you're running ie 11 as
ie8 that's not really ie8 that's an
emulated form of ie8 it's a compat mode
and there's bugs in the compat mode that
don't show up in the normal version and
underscore and low dash patch
issues with that in it in the library
and so i need to test that
and with
with salsa labs i can i basically detect
a query string i set the header for the
file because you you can set compat
modes inside a meta tag or you can set
compat modes uh with the h the html
header
for the header for the html file and so
i do it that way so i can have the exact
same unit test that's running all of my
browser tests also run the compat mode
tests
too what's also nice is concurrent
tunnels so it's not just run one unit
test suite
wait for it to complete start another
start another that would take forever
this allows concurrent test uh tunnels
so you can have tests uh running at the
same time
there's limits for the free account
there's like a limit of three uh i upped
mine to 10
but 10 has been more than i've ever
needed and i do a lot of variations here
like i mentioned earlier with all of the
builds and the minifieds and all of that
automatic retries so this is something
i've been working on
it's it's not available in the
grunt
plugin yet but
it's what it does is
this this is running tests from travis
ci it's opening a tunnel from travis ci
to sauce labs and running unit tests and
a lot of weird stuff can happen on the
net like some connections could be
dropped something could be hanging
somewhere causing it to fail and it's
not my fault it's not the it's not my
codes fault it's not failing unit tests
there's a connection issue
and normally that would that would cause
the their test run to fail and that
would cause my travis job to fail and
each one of my i have three travis runs
for the the monolithic build and that's
each one has like eight
sauce labs connections and so that means
if one of those eight fail my entire
travis job fails and it says my unit
tests fail for that so it's very
important that i don't have false
positives creeping up because it could
be very chatty and making me always have
to double check my work which is
annoying um so what i've added was
retries and all the place and all the
things so it does things like q unit how
many people use q unit
not a lot i tell you what i i use q unit
because it was available at the time
and because underscore and backbone use
it and i want compatibility with them so
what i did was i made q unit work in all
the environments that it doesn't
naturally work in so i made it work in
node i made it work in java
by by
shimming
set timeout
set interval and clear timeout and all
of those things and get got it working
there so i'm i found this this
this way to make it work i use it it's
called cue unit extras which is the note
on the bottom there and that's my shim
for adding
things like retries to q units so one of
the things that bit me with browser test
automation is asynchronous tests
anything that relies on set timeout and
so lodash has the bounce and throttle
and i have unit tests that rely on
pauses there and when you're testing in
old browsers those timeouts and those
timers have really poor resolution and
there could be things going on in the
background that caused them to drift and
when they drift you get false fails so
what i've added was q unit.config dot
async retries and so you can specify how
many times you want an async test to
retry before it gives up and so in my
case it's 10 times
so if any one of those 10 times passes i
get a pass from the test i don't have a
problem with false positives it's always
been false negatives if the test is
going to fail it's always going to fail
but the timer drift could cause false
fails every once in a while so i need to
try that
the other thing i've added was retries
to jobs so before i said hey there could
be a connection issue and that could
cause
a job to hang um so i detect that and if
there's a problem with the job that's
not test related i retry the job and so
that requires um stopping the job
deleting the job creating a new job and
continuing on and if there's a lot of
problems with the jobs it could mean
there's a problem with the tunnel
the tunnel connection could be corrupt
and if there's a problem with the tunnel
then i stop all the jobs remove all the
jobs and then restart the tunnel and
continue where i left off
so when i've done that i get a super
stable
browser test automation i don't get
false fails i've been tweeting about
this recently where i had like 100 runs
with no false fails and then i had two
weeks with no false fails and so i just
keep refining that and getting it more
and more stable and i've even added
mobile testing which i'll cover in a bit
and even that completely stable just i
know if it fails it's unit test related
and it's not just the setup
tailored platforms so before i said
hey you can do compat testing right for
ie but if i'm doing compat mode testing
that means i'm not interested in firefox
and chrome and safari right because this
is ie compat modes so you can do things
like say okay i'm testing
ie
compat modes i know i don't need those
browsers or i'm testing amd modules
right so then i know i don't need some
old version of opera that doesn't work
with that so you can tailor based on
what you're testing and so i can i can
detect that by the tags that i assign to
things and only and make sure that of my
browser matrix i only test the ones that
it's relevant to
next so going into some of the cool
here's an example
of the tiny bit of code
that is required to set the header for
uh the ie compat mode and you can see
there if you want to go to my repo which
is uh low dash
low dash and then go to test and
saucelabs.js you'll see this in there
too
and that actually does the the sniff for
the dot html and then sets the header
for compat mode and that's all you do
i'm not sure you can do that with
something like tesling which is why i
like i like sauce labs sauce labs also
allows me to do things like have a
screencast of my my failed test so i can
run it and see exactly what error and
when and what's helpful there is to say
for a gliese for q unit is to say hide
passing tests so it only shows the ones
that have failed
you can actually go a step further and
and tell sauce labs which tests have
failed and they'll do a really pretty
printout that doesn't require a
screencast or anything
i just haven't done that yet so
okay five minutes
all right that's awesome so here's
here's the i always think i'm going to
be short on time but this is cool
this is an example of filtering
platforms here so i just say hey if it's
a compat mode i filter it down to the
relevant
user agents and browsers
and this is the secret sauce to doing
anything with sauce labs and that was
something that i had to kind of find out
on my own it's better documented now but
at the time it wasn't and that is if you
even have a custom unit testing
framework you just have to set global
test results which is a global variable
uh to
um
your details object so and your details
object can have a pass and a failed
count and that's the minimum it needs
right but you can add like an error
message too if you want
but that's all you need no matter what
unit testing your framework you're using
as soon as you set that global object it
will detect it and then
close out that connection for that
browser and say all right and and report
back the results
so the other option instead of making
travis ci do it if you've seen the hefty
travis.yml you're probably thinking well
that's not for me well i made it up for
me
for you you might like the grunt way to
do it and the grunt way to do it is
fairly straightforward
there is a project by peru sharon
a ms opentech employee i believe this
might be on his own time though
and it's called grunt sauce labs
and this allows you to fairly easily by
configuring a config that looks a lot
like just a regular object with your
your the unit testing framework you want
to use some paths some browser names
inversions you want to use and that's it
it handles a lot of the stuff that i had
to stumble along
the way
for you in fact i was really surprised
when i started doing research for this
that
uh the thing that i came up with looks
really close to the thing that they have
except their issues is grunt and mine
uses traffic ci
so i would recommend using
this this project for that
here's an example uh of just
of of what it would look like the config
you can see you just specify your
browsers your platform your version and
maybe some paths in there and uh a port
and and that's really it this is taken
from winjs which was recently open
sourced they use uh the grunt sauce labs
as well
and they use q unit here
and so that's really all you have to do
to set up your stuff which makes it very
nice
so some of the things that made me go
hmm these are more more of the stumbling
blocks you'll see at the bottom i've
crossed out some i'll cover those in a
bit
so i'm not a ruby dev i'm javascript all
the way
but in order to get this to work for
travis ci i had to do gym install travis
uh mess with encrypted strings
so
here i there's questions like does
secure inside your travis yml work with
multiple variables does it environment
variables how does all of that sort out
so the the basic ideas is you go travis
encrypt sauce that capitalize sauce
access key and your access key from your
account
and then you can put that in your travis
yml
with dash secure and whatever that
encrypted string is and so what what
travis ci does on the back end is take
that and actually turn that into the
legit environment variable uh the global
test results i've already covered and
android testing was a big pain and what
the problem there was is that i believe
it has to deal with http or i'm sorry
html headers um
and um
headers for javascript files it seems to
be very picky about that so what i was
getting in my mobile testing were files
that would load as valid javascript but
only partially load the file and then
throw syntax errors which was really
frustrating to to solve so what i do is
i i add in on a window on error handler
that detects the error
tells the unit test that it's done
running and reports the error back and
then my retry logic goes hey there was
an error running this test why don't you
retry that test and then i retry it and
hopefully that issue is resolved it's
not a very
consistent issue but that mobile testing
one that was really tricky
there's no longer an issue with sauce
tunnel so you don't have to worry about
that special version and there's no
longer an issue with an undocumented
tunnel id key that was fun to find
that's been resolved too they've just
refreshed their documentation and made
everything super easy
for more information on their docs you
can go to docs slash rest slash
additional config
connect and get tons and tons of
information this thing is super
configurable the rest api is what i use
because i didn't want to deal with a
web driver so i just i take the url i i
post a request with a json object and
then i just check it and i do everything
from there you can delete jobs you can
rename jobs the list kind of goes on and
on and on with how configurable these
things are so i would say check that out
and i think i'm done and there is no
questions so that's it
awesome
so
you